thank you
[Music]
the bed and beyond CFO has gone beyond
Bed and Beyond Bed Bath and Beyond did
he pass away
yes why'd you out there or did he go to
the spirit realm Beyond this realm well
I don't know aren't those two the same
I don't know I didn't Gotta Die to go
spoynos the headline is the Bed Bath and
Beyond CFO has gone beyond [ __ ] dead
no because you ever watched that movie
Click where he opens the door and he
just goes to the Beyond section and it's
like out of this Christopher Walken I do
remember that oh that's right that world
okay it's probably not where he is
I thought that was Adam Sandler what
hasn't gone beyond recently is
unfortunately Bed Bath and Beyond's
shares they are down uh 20 today oh did
they pump up like crazy yeah because it
was Wall Street bets they they pumped it
so yeah there was a huge Groundswell of
what they call retail investors right
who are excited about the price of Bed
Bath and Beyond they were buying it like
almost targeting it through Wall Street
bets and they were driving the price up
so the price got as high as like 20
something bucks
and then the Bed Bath and Beyond uh
shareholders started to dump it all over
the [ __ ] place right and they crashed
the price all the way down
um so the 20 coupons I give out that's
what it is dude they give them away
every week too that's why they dropped
20 and even the stocks and they figured
out that the expiration date is like
totally doesn't matter it doesn't matter
they always seem to work have you guys
bought anything from there yeah not
recently what was the last thing you
bought at Bed Bath I've never left there
without Nikki spending like 500 there do
I love that place they buy stupid boring
[ __ ] like [ __ ] like like you know
towels and it's like like oh curtains
can I say one thing about women
this is gonna sound sexist hey this is a
safe place don't say this to my wife all
the time yeah I already agree too women
love buying stuff
for no reason yeah like for no [ __ ]
reason they just like they like clutter
they like cluttering up the house yes
buying stuff that just they just want to
put stuff in the house so we've spent
550 on like towels I don't understand
[ __ ] women dude [ __ ] stupid ass
women buying all this [ __ ] you need a
new yeah hold up both of your guitars
please we need two at your Spears for
some reason we already have blankets at
our house but we need these new blankets
because they're really soft feel how
soft it's seasonal dude you know how
many pillows are on our bed we have
seven pillows on our bed or two people
you know how many you only have seven
pillows you know you know I mean my wife
does he uses she uses zero she sleeps on
nope is it for style why do they do this
with the pillows I don't understand so
what he does too is for some reason and
I only know this because I'll fall
asleep downstairs when I come upstairs
and then I'll be laying down in bed and
I'll [ __ ] hit my knee on wood I'm
like why is my knee hitting wood well
it's because Nikki puts this like little
cute tray it's like this cute little
bamboo tray it's got like a [ __ ]
table book on it for no reason yeah and
it's got like a candle here oh dude
table books why why is this on the bed
it's on the [ __ ] foot of the bed so
and I'm six foot four and a half what is
it for look it's just do they put the
tray here so she likes the candle and
reads the book Vibes or something it's
all for Vibes Good Housekeeping catalog
bro we have soap we have stacks of books
that are not for reading they're just
for looks they're just to be on top of
the table and in our house we don't have
like a dining table to eat so we eat in
the living room on our like coffee table
right and there's just so many [ __ ]
books on there I can't even fit like
more than one plate yeah on the [ __ ]
table what's the book got in it it dude
it's like crystals no don't
the history of [ __ ] Aviation
but it's a cool it's a cool cover you
know what I mean yeah yeah you don't use
the book black and white with like maybe
the planes colored though yeah
does it also mention astrology and like
yeah there's something like that you
know it's just there's just so much
things in our house that are not used
for what they should be used for I'm
like hey I got an idea so it's been 550
on towels and blankets we already have
both by the way and we get a
Margaritaville which we don't have and
that's and that's 500 or I think I know
what we do with it yeah but God forbid
we buy a Margaritaville for the house
exactly God forbid we have a [ __ ]
nice little delightful Margaritaville
that we can use anytime we want I
remember I looked at uh Bed Bath and
Beyond and I was looking for [ __ ] to get
and I just couldn't click the checkout
button because I knew I could have got
the same [ __ ] at Ross that's right
that's not well
Marshall's Ross TJ Maxx they all have
the they have really good and also Home
Goods Home Goods has all the stuff that
you can get at Bed Bath Home Goods
that's a that's a yes I like Home Goods
I think you haven't lived with the chick
for long enough yet with your new chick
yeah long enough yet you don't know
Hannah because she's a thrifter exactly
like once her ass gets in Home Goods
you're going to Home Goods every week
Home Goods is bro there's a line at the
[ __ ] no she's the one that goes oh my
God why are you gonna buy that I'm like
it's five dollars and she goes here's
the same thing for one dollar and I'm
like I love you so much [ __ ] do this
he's the spender in the relationship it
is that's the [ __ ] truth you do have
two guitars you don't play it was a gift
God damn it
so this guy he killed himself right yeah
he did he jumped off just because their
financials were so [ __ ] up well he's
being they're being they're being
investigated right so so um they pumped
and dumped is what they're being
investigated for that's what everyone
believes happened because it seems like
that's what happened
um because this there was um
there was a stakeholder
um who shared fake Revenue numbers and
Company plans for spinning off its Bye
Bye Baby brand like b-y-b-u-y baby brand
so people were like oh [ __ ] at Bed Bath
and Beyond is getting into baby space
that will be good for the shares right
and and they shared fake Revenue numbers
as well so it's like it was like they
look as a coordinated plan to
artificially inflate the price of the
stock that they then dumped into right
yeah so is this the reason why it hyped
up like The Wall Street bets group or
did they just do it as like a meme again
though there's both right so like it was
like this was done and then the Wall
Street bets guys started to like go
around it like honey right but there was
definitely already a Groundswell of
support from the wealthy best community
because they're picking a lot of stocks
over the last like you know 24 months or
whatever since all that stuff started
like they're picking like not just
GameStop but they're picking like all
these other stocks and so little groups
little tribes of them would have like
say Bed Bath and Beyond and then they
would be trying to get people excited
about it right so yeah yeah so but but
there's there's an investigation now
once the investigation got announced
um that's what people believe made this
this guy named Gustavo Arnold here's the
CFO uh jumped to his death from a
high-rise apartment in Manhattan you
know what the um kind of the irony apart
about all this is so I read somewhere
where
so you remember the whole Robin Hood
[ __ ] with Wall Street beds and then like
they couldn't Cash Out GameStop and then
they link it all back to Citadel being
the owner and the [ __ ] culprit for
all this [ __ ] right and so Citadel
caught wind and studied all this Wall
Street they're a hedge fund yeah they're
a hedge fund that that owned Robin Hood
they're the ones that allegedly told
Robin Hood to stop the [ __ ] buy one
so you know and then they had a stake in
in and and they didn't want to get
shorted out whatever
so
everyone was like let's stick it to the
team to Citadel but Citadel figured this
[ __ ] out and apparently they benefited
from [ __ ] Bed Bath and Beyond's pump
so Wall Street bet pumped it and made
[ __ ] money for Citadel yeah and
they're trying to stick it to citizens
who said that was longing it maybe Yeah
Yeah ironic
no it [ __ ] sucks yeah but that's what
they do right those the money
manipulators are really good at what
they do like you can beat them for a
while but eventually you'll figure it
out yeah but they're there for a reason
right because they figured it out when
when a dude like this kills himself does
that usually mean that he would have
been arrested for something all we know
is that his he left no note his wife
actually saw him jump oh yeah
traumatizing and and there's no like you
know he didn't tell her anything about
anything or like so we it's it's tough
to say or tough to to just say like he
knew he was guilty of something we just
don't know he didn't say the SEC is up
my [ __ ] ass right yeah that happened
with Enron too right didn't like
somebody kill themselves to avoid but at
least but in Steve Green's opinion yeah
if you had to go on the whim yeah would
you say he jumped because he would have
probably gone to jail I think that he he
probably
um he he was excited about how the price
was up yeah right yeah and then he's
like
[ __ ] I'm gonna put more into it yeah
I think that's what happened
I think he followed the pump yeah
because he saw the [ __ ] pop and he
was like I I can't stay out of this he's
like this is my own company sounds like
something I did
but you're still here I know because
this stuff is stupid like why kill
yourself over it that's why I feel like
maybe there's some other [ __ ] going on
because there are countless numbers of
dudes that
[ __ ] this happens all the time like
in finance and [ __ ] like not all the
time but obviously like like there's
they're just [ __ ] they'll pay it off
or whatever you don't think that guy was
happy it could be his wife was nagging
the [ __ ] she was buying too much [ __ ]
and he has nothing to do with hitting
his [ __ ] knee on the wooden thing she
was just nagging that's why she saw him
he's like you think for like three
months maybe he's like baby we can get
whatever you want you know but like
after we do this a couple times if we
could just maybe pick up that
Margaritaville
and she's like on Bed Bath and Beyond
buying all this [ __ ] hey babe can you
get the Margaritaville and she's like
yeah sweetheart I'll get it didn't get
it okay
four more times and then he checks it
and it says out of stock of the
Margaritaville he's like oh these other
husbands get hooked up
everyone's getting her for Father's day
except for me he can't bear to show up
at the Elks Lodge and he's like you know
if we don't get the Margaritaville now
they're gonna have this new model and I
don't you know it's not an ice container
it's like it's not a glass container if
you can't get this for me can then you
at least get the singing bass on the
wall like can I just get one of those he
like adds to card it's like this is in
12 other people's carts just [ __ ] buy
it it says it says there's only seven
remaining you have to do the math
and then he jumped out yeah then he
jumped yeah probably that's what
happened